if you haven't had a chance to watch how
Camino on Netflix yet make a u-turn and
queue it up if you have seen it carry on
as we dissect the ending and figure out
what it all meant major spoilers ahead
it's no exaggeration to say that Jesse
Pinkman went through a lot to join the
original series he was chained up
extorted held hostage by a fly and beats
him within an inch of his life and to
top it all off he was present while two
of his girlfriends died through it all
this was a guy who was on the run
sometimes that was literal sometimes
more figurative as he ran from his
choices in life think about the first
and last time he ever laid eyes on Jesse
the first time we ever saw him in action
he was running from the cops the last
time he was speeding into the night
running away from the neo-nazi compound
he's framed by the chase from beginning
to end
get some help no one is trying to hurt
you son and in our Camino Jesse spends a
good chunk of time on the run as well
he's basically public enemy number one
as we see when a caravan of police cars
screams onto the scene at the first
sniff of Jesse's whereabouts by the end
of it all he finally finds a place to
stop running and maybe just maybe finds
a little piece just before the title
card cuts in we see a hint of a smile
pass over his lips whatever comes next
for Jesse he'll be forging his own path
through a brand new frontier Breaking
Bad's body count is ridiculously high
and many of those corpses are added to
the pile by Walter White's himself for
his part Jesse Pinkman has surprisingly
little blood on his hands over the
course of five seasons the only directly
caused the deaths of three people cartel
enforcer Joaquin Salamanca naive coffee
lover Gail petaca and closet psychopath
Todd Alquist every one of those deaths
ate him up inside well except maybe
Todd's but jesse is no killer it'd
rather get arrested than shoot a police
officer and there's a point where he
can't even bring himself to shoot Todd
after everything the guy put him through
but by the climactic showdown in the
film jesse is ready to do whatever it
takes for his freedom it's a darker edge
to the absolution he wants but it shows
that he's done being a prisoner or a
pawn you
yeah it's possible that he doesn't
realize it right away but the flashback
with Jane's suggests that he does come
to an understanding about their they
talk about going where the universe
takes you and Jesse is on board with the
philosophy until Jane brings him back
down to earth I've gone where the
universe takes me in my whole life it's
better to make those decisions for
yourself it's no accident that the
flashback occurs just before the final
shot of Jesse driving away he's finally
taking control of his life and made
those decisions for himself the cats out
of the bag Walter White is back in El
Camino but there's no miraculous return
to life here it's just a flashback to a
conversation Jesse and Walt had in a New
Mexico diner it appears to take place to
turn the events of the season two
episode that saw them trapped in the
desert just before Jesse dropped Walt
off at the airport judging by their
clothes the conversation is seemingly
innocuous and let's be honest is mainly
a way to get bryan cranston back into
the role for one last hurrah but it also
suggests hints for Jesse's new future
Walt urges him to think about going back
to college then says you're really lucky
you didn't have to wait your whole life
to do something special it's Jesse
finally doing something that he sees a
special
although Walter was probably referring
to things like making piles of money and
becoming a respected drug kingpin Jesse
may see putting his regrets and mistakes
in the past as a more personal measure
of what makes something special before
Jesse parts ways with ed in Alaska he
pulls an envelope from its pocket and
asks Edie to mail for him as one last
favor
inside is a handwritten letter and when
Jesse drives away we see that it's
addressed to Brock Conti Oh
the son of his girlfriend Andrea whom
Todd shot what does a letter say the
film never shows us but most likely is
an apology to Brock and maybe even an
explanation so he doesn't spend his
whole life living with a question mark
of his mother's death in the first scene
of the film Mike Ehrmantraut tells
Jessie that while he may be able to
start fresh the one thing he can never
do is make things right and maybe a
letter from his mom's boyfriend's won't
change Brookes life but to Jesse it's
important to try he won't bring back
Brock's mom with the letter but it may
at least bring a smidgen of closure to a
tragedy which in Brock's eyes came
out of nowhere and had no apparent
course the folks behind breaking bad if
often described how the clothing on the
show it's assigned to clued viewers into
a character's mental state for example
Walter White starts out wearing beige
but his clothes get darker the more he
transforms into Heisenberg showrunner
Vince Gilligan told vulture color is
important on Breaking Bad we always
tried to think in terms of it we always
tried to think of the color that a
character is dressed in in the sense
that it represents on some level the
state of mind that trend continued all
the way to the end of El Camino when
Jesse steps out of the shower he's
dressed himself in all black he even
gets a last-minute gift from Pete a
black beanie completing the look but
when he drives off on his own in Alaska
he's done the white sweater the wardrobe
shift takes Jesse from a character
consumed by in a turmoil into a man
who's driving a single road into a
brighter cleaner future even the
flashback scene with Walt in the diner
pays attention to this earlier in their
partnership Jesse was still clinging to
the good inside em plenty of white in
his outfit conflicted sure but not yet
giving in to anger loss and despair
it took Jesse a while to find the right
clothes again but he's finally leaving
some of that darkness behind in spite of
all the positive connotations there's a
bitterness to the ending of El Camino
that's hard to deny jesse is truly
completely alone anyone else you want to
say goodbye to when he ventures into
obscurity in Alaska he does so with only
memories of the people he once cared
about that's not to say that viewers
weren't warned that it would come to
this prior to El Caminos premiere Aaron
Paul tweeted a scene from season 3 of
the series along with the caption cats
out of the bag and the bag is in the
river he has a moment from Breaking Bad
to slowly prepare you all for what's to
come in that scene jesse is at his
emotional wits end and flat-out turns
down Walters offered to keep working
together Jesse tells him with
heartbreaking intensity I have never
been more alone
[Music]
unfortunately that hasn't changed by the
ending of El Camino if anything he's
even more alone than ever was it all
worth it in the end hopefully the answer
is check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
buy your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]